the end is nigh brady the the time is
coming to an end and i can tell you
actually precisely
when time is going to end it's going to
end
at 3 a.m
3 14
and seven seconds
on the 19th
of january
2038.
what's going on is we're talking about
the end of unix time
now
you're making a face at me like you
don't know what i'm talking about brady
most of us at home are using either
windows or mac based operating systems
um
for our computers and somewhere buried
deep down inside that system is a little
counter that's been ticking away
every second
it's a past second every second
since january the 1st 1970 they began
encounter in a 32-bit number crucially
that was just going to count seconds
and obviously because it's only a 32-bit
number
it's going to run out at some point that
is the point this is the moment
when that number
runs out of seconds to count this is how
your computer is telling the time this
is how your computer is keeping the date
so you can take this number the number
of seconds and you can divide it
and keep dividing it and keep dividing
it to get back to the number of minutes
hours days years that have passed
since january the first 1970.
so this is what's called the unix epoch
now the reason i keep talking about unix
is because way back then
there was
there was this operating system called
unix
which
was just beginning to really take a hold
in corporations and really mission
critical systems the point is in every
single one of those mission critical
machines
there's a number ticking away counting
the seconds
and it's ticking towards
january the 19th 2038 when it's gonna
run out and when it does a very weird
thing's going to happen it's going to
roll back
to i think it's december 1901
so in some ways it's great because it's
an opportunity for us to to redo the
20th century and maybe get it right this
time
but in other ways it's going to be
absolutely catastrophic because
it's a lot like the millennium bugs so
some of your viewers were too young to
remember the millennium bug but but
those of us that were there the
millennium bug was a problem when we
were storing the date as a two-digit
number in a lot of computers
mostly back in the 80s
and everybody thought you know it's a
long way away we're not going to have to
worry about what happens when we get to
2000 but it just turns out that once
you've got a computer that works say if
you're in a bank or if you're you know
running an airline you have a system
that works
it costs too much to bother changing
that so things get left just working for
years and years and years and it came up
to 2000 and all of these computers were
just going to fail in some obscure way
so a lot of the time the date started
showing
as 19
100. or if it was a system which was
dependent on the incremental date like
it's adding interest to your bank
account then suddenly it was going to go
from being 99 to being zero and it was
going to add a huge amount of negative
interest to your bank account which is
good if you've got a mortgage and
terrible if you've you've got savings i
worked on this for a few years leading
up to the millennium
and we went around and we fixed all of
the machines that were were too old to
survive the millennium and of course
everybody knows um it wasn't a problem
in the end okay so there were a few
cases some sad cases and some quite
funny cases
where it did go wrong but for the most
part it wasn't a problem so we have to
go back to the pac-man video that we did
where we were talking about binary
numbers and in pacman we were storing
that binary number as an 8-bit binary
value and that meant that it could count
up to a maximum of 256.
now it's a choice it's either a maximum
of 256 and a minimum of zero
or a minimum of a minus 128 and a
maximum of 127.
so this value has been running from a
minimum of -2 billion
to a maximum of plus two billion and
this is the moment
when it reaches that maximum value of
two billion it's not it's not actually
two billion it's about two billion uh
150 million but it's a big number when i
turn my computer off at home and it
hasn't got electricity
obviously it's not counting anymore is
it it's not counting anymore um but
there is a battery inside
which is storing its current state so it
depends on how your computer's set up
some computers are set up
to
connect immediately to server and get
the current time just to make sure that
all of those computers are synchronized
across the network other computers like
your home computer
are set up just to read the date or the
time
from a memory chip which has been
keeping it stored with the cmos battery
what we're going to have to do very
simply same solution as always with
these things we've got to throw away the
machines which have got two smaller
number and replace them with bigger
versions and that's all already
beginning to happen we're already moving
from 32-bit computers which count in
32-bit numbers to 64-bit computers which
which come up in 64-bit numbers and with
a 64-bit counter
then then this problem is pushed out an
awfully long way and actually that
number is is somewhere way beyond the
end of of the known universe way beyond
the heat death of the universe is it
going to be a date when everyone's
worried do you think do you think this
is going to be panic stations when this
time comes yes i think there'll be a
problem because
i remember being in a bank in 1999 quite
a long time ago now and looking at the
oldest computer i had ever seen and
somebody's saying oh that's just our
payment system and you know it just
worked you know they used that word just
and nobody had ever thought about it and
i had to look at that machine and say
well you know what your payment system
is not going to work next week we need
to fix that and i don't doubt for a
second that there will be 32-bit
computers sitting in the corner of some
dusty bank building society or airline
or whatever in 2038
they're going to just
go wrong
and all of those bookings for your
holiday and malaga are all going to be
erased in some horrible way so i don't
think it's going to go wrong in any
life-threatening manner but yeah
there'll be some comical errors and
certainly for people like me who know
how to fix this problem there's a great
opportunity to well this is my pension
we're talking about here i'm going to go
around upgrading 32-bit computers to
64-bit computers to pay for the last 30
years of my life i'm looking forward to
it already you can go through and you
can pick out you know key dates in in
unix numbers and the 9th of september
was 1 billion and quite a few people
celebrated that and there was a small
celebration in norway for one billion
one hundred and eleven million one
hundred and eleven thousand one hundred
and eleven and so yeah people here
people are noticing unix time ticking
away but for most of us you know it's
happening behind our backs
so well what we have here is is the
current unix time at 1.34
billion so
if you're feeling really smart at home
apart from the fact that the dates in
the top corner of the screen
you could work out when we're actually
filming this because this is the number
that the computer uses to calculate this
date
it's like watching your life just
taken away